thank you everyone as we continue to get
situated here um we have the members of
two different subcommittees up here and
a special guest um I'll make sure that
as we're voting we're only including
those um subcommittee members our first
work session that we'll have it'll start
in just a moment is for House Bill 608
that's the establishing a pilot program
to support the Bureau of devel
Developmental Services redesign and
that's myself representative Nagel
kofalt Weber Merchant and frus um at
1:30 we will have the work session on on
House Bill 317 establishing a commission
to study transitioning to a two-tier
waiver system that's myself
representative n Nagel kofalt Weber and
nut upam um so with that change we don't
necessarily need to shuffle out of our
chairs representative McKay is joining
us today and since he'll be voting on it
as a full committee um I'm welcoming
here him here as well and I'll make sure
to get him a copy if you just give me
just one more moment to shuffle my
started
thank you good afternoon and welcome to
the work session on House Bill
608 um this bill was initially
introduced before any of the changes
happened and so what we've been able to
see in the meantime is that the
implementation um has been proceeding
but there have been some challenges of
the implementation um I think the
largest question we have here is what
the status is how we're moving forward
um what oversight is necessary and what
support the legislature can provide to
make sure that if we are an observant
part of this process we understand what
the actual needs are of the department
and of the community so that as if we're
able to move forward and keep an eye and
work together we can understand if
there's anything that we needs to be
introduced next year to make sure that
this department is able to function in
the way that we need it to because quite
frankly the this the people that are
served by this department are the people
that if for to help anybody as a
government they they're absolutely who
we owee help to because they they're
very important people that may not have
the cap the ability to do everything
that they need to on their own and their
parents won't live long enough to take
care of them for their entire lives so
this is one of the very very very
important things we do as a government
and I think that we need to have good
important care to make sure that is
executed as we need and then we also
make sure the department is empowered as
they need in order order to meet the
challenges that we
see so um as this is a work session um
it's not a hearing so it's not the same
issue of pink cards but this is a
dynamic situation so we want to make
sure that we're able to hear from those
involved those impacted and that we can
understand sort of what's going on now
um I do have an amendment that would
sort of update the language of this to
um I don't have the actual Amendment
back yet but I did provide my requests
to um o L and the amendment simply would
change the date of when it would start
and and instead of just saying the
commissioner shall not Implement uh BDS
redesign prior to July 21st and to Halt
other processes that it would say that
the commissioner shall not Implement
aspect yes could I ask if would you tell
us exactly where on the bill you're
changing things yes my
apology can line it in thank you there's
been a few moving pieces and that's why
um I was hoping to have the actual draft
so this is on page one lines 3 through 7
uh Roman
1 to change it to read in that first
line establish a sequence of pilot
projects um and to have the start date
be July 1st um although obviously if
this is a process that is going to be
helpful it says no later than it so this
isn't something that requires
legislative approval so the idea of
working through pilot projects um could
be could be done even without enacting
this and the idea would that be that the
commissioner shall not Implement aspects
of the BDS redesign prior to
demonstrating that the changes do not
threaten the stability of the state
Service delivery system as defined by
RSA 171a colon4 or the provision of care
to individuals in the system and further
that integration of the full system
redesign shall be trialed before
Statewide
implementation Madam chair yes I may
again yes being a visual can you put
your sorry I'm I'm a visual learner
rather than an auditory learner which is
why I have trouble with the uh did you
pass that out I did pass that out I
think that's sitting under your smaller
smaller device it's the one that I
printed from my email so it's the one
email the other section that we have yes
printed email should be in that stuff if
not I may have done a bad job of
Distributing you may have had got I we
go it's under everything thank you I'm
sorry I just want to be sure we're all
on the same page here oh not problem and
having the having the language in front
of me is helpful I I appreciate that and
this may just be a starting point but
it's a matter of trying to make sure
that um everybody is proceeding together
towards system
success the other section um is on page
one line 26 through page two line two
it's simply to take away the interim
report because uh that time has already
passed the idea for an inter interim
report that would have been due to days
ago is uh
unnecessary so that is the general idea
that I'm looking towards that it may
make sense to continue this in this
process with the idea of the pilot
program and move this forward um through
the house and through the Senate so that
if this does remain necessary by the
time the Senate deals with this business
that it's available to us without having
to come in as a non derain Amendment
anywhere um and I'm hopeful that we will
continue to have good communication
between the legislature and the
department and everybody involved in
this process so that we can make sure
that this system is as strong and robust
as
possible and um with that I am actually
very thankful to um have Christine
santanello I hope I pronounced that
correctly I should have asked before um
here from the from the bureau to um help
explain to us sort of what's gone on and
the
process fantastic
when it's all about a team right thank
you and so if everybody can introduce
themselves once you get settled but I
know there's always a rearranging of
furniture that happens we did the same
up
here okay can you hear me okay good
afternoon I am Chris santinello I am
associate commissioner at the Department
of Health and Human
Services good afternoon Nathan white
Chief Financial Officer of the
Department of Health and Human
Services good afternoon Melissa Hardy
division director for long-term supports
and services for the department so thank
you very much um for having us here
today and I did share some information
with representative Leon did that get
distributed um thank you yes the email
that I received earliest was emailed out
to everybody um I believe the other one
went out as well but I have copies for
everybody on the committee I just know
at the Timeline it would be good to go
over it because some of us are visual
some of us are auditory and it's good to
make sure everybody's on the same page
sure so I actually just wanted to
basically start um by saying that the um
Department I have to put my glasses on
sorry um is committed to meeting and
collaborating with all stakeholders um
to continually improve the developmental
disability um Services System for our
current and future um participants um we
fully understand that change any type of
change or organizational change in um
Services is hard for everybody um
including the department I mean some of
these changes were really hard on us as
well um and we will continue to support
providers during this change um I think
there's a little bit here that I just
wanted to clarify as to what was
compliance driven and what is optional
um and really meant to improve the
service system because I believe that's
really important for us to and some of
that is in your information
um but I think really what we want to do
is um pause on some of the improvements
while we finish out the changes that
were needed for compliance and I think
that's what everybody um is concerned
with um and we support that and I think
we really want to improve the system
working and listening together with
everybody um hearing all thoughts ideas
and Views because some different ideas
may come up and I believe some new ideas
already have come up um so first of all
um for compliance that is conflict of
interest so that's where a
provider cannot be the provider of the
direct service and the case management
um so that is a that was compliance and
direct Bill those have been in effect
the department was under a corrective
action plan in
2017 um we had three extensions and we
EX costed all of our extensions and
Melissa can highlight that if needed um
what direct bill means is a huge um
shift to the system prior um to July 1st
all billing was done through the area
agency system and what Medicaid says is
each provider of a Medicaid services has
to be enrolled independently in Medicaid
and have the option to Bill on their own
so those were two big shifts to the
system the other compliance
um area is electronic visit verification
known as evv and that has been around
since
2016 so those are the compliance things
that we have to get done the system
Innovation work um includes our
participant directed and manag services
that's where individuals and families
direct some of their services and we um
have a desire and a need to strengthen
that for individuals and families and
also look at the rate for the Financial
Management Services really
differentiating what is a transactional
financial um Management Service and what
is really the support individuals and
families need to do that well the other
um change we want to look at and we've
engaged with Meyers and sta
um is our rate work and looking at
starting at the cost of the direct
support professional and building out
rates based on that person so those are
the two areas that the department has
slated as our next steps um once we
finish the change from direct bill um
and
we definitely can push all of that work
out there are no strict timelines um we
want to work on the rates clearly
because that's an issue for Workforce
for projecting for our next budget cycle
right but and those rates are different
than the hb2 rate so I just want to make
sure people understand that um so we
really have the ability and are
committed um to engage with stakeholders
and hear about needs ideas um and so
that to guide our future work
so thank you representative Weber
thank you very much Madam chair and
thank you for taking my question so
having had that as a framework if we
could turn to the bill and the proposed
amendments and I don't know if you have
seen the proposed
amendments are there copies of the
proposed amendments that they might be
able to look at I'm in one of my stats
and I will find where that is okay my my
question once you have been provided
with a copy and I could perhaps give one
to M Dyer to to see um I would just like
to know if the bill with the amendment
is going to
foot not with my
great can can I I just take a second to
look at it sure
absolutely and my apologies for not
before
in okay ready so I think and I I'd
actually like Melissa Hardy question
yeah my question really is uh is this
language going to create more problems
than it solves or is this something that
is a decent plan going forward so I
think we
can we know we can do this without
legislation um and and Melissa can talk
a little bit about the how we have
planned to roll out any of the changes
with participant directed Services which
we haven't even set a date for so that's
in the future but for the rate work um
what we really wanted to do is some
testing in with a couple of providers
and a couple of services to really flush
out is this working is it helping and so
we have that already as part of our work
and I think that because we report
quarterly I believe to HHS oversight
committee that's a place where we could
provide updates but I'd like Melissa to
jump in thank you I think as Chris said
I think you know in in speaking with our
stakeholders and with our area agencies
and providers um I think we can come to
a place where we can work together as a
collaborative system um to again pause
any sort of system Innovation work we're
looking to do not looking um at um the
past work that's been done and that
we're still doing as far as compliance
but I feel like as a system we can come
together and operate and and and really
develop what we need without having it
being legislated um just as
professionals as individuals um and as
provider agency so having just seen this
like it's hard to give you a gut
reaction on how that would impact that
work but in having these conversations
ongoing with area agencies and providers
I think as a system we should be able to
come up with a system collaboratively
without
legislation
follow okay so so my concern is this um
at the last hearing uh we and and at the
initial hearings um we heard very loudly
from a number of people who felt that
wasn't happening which is why there's
leg legislation proposed in the first
place uh so that's issue number one and
and then more specifically what we heard
at the last hearing was the issue of
agencies that uh because there have been
any number of different sorts of
creative
reimbursement schemes are now
theoretically owing back
more then I mean they're really under
Financial strain of the sort which may
result in the loss of service providers
and uh that is a matter of extreme
concern to all of us and so I guess what
I'd like to hear as a little bit of an
update is how that is being
addressed
and
if I still haven't had a direct answer
to my question which was if we enact
this is it going to put a roadblock in
the way I I have heard very clearly you
say that this is not necessary for you
to do the kinds of things that it's
suggesting that you can already do them
but um I kind of want to hear about
those other two things so I'll stop
talking there let you answer so let me
get to the financial stability questions
and that's why I have our trusty uh CFO
here with us um so what happened is so
actually as of and it's all of this is
in your information um through October
23rd a total of
1.6.9 million has been paid out um to
agencies now we did have to over the
summer
what that's what I
said 106.9 sorry that's the smaller of
the two that I handed to you the two
pages and that's on the second
page
I did 1 million yeah we'd all know be
sitting here right
um so of that um
63.8 million has been paid to area
agencies and this was a combination of
some manual payments um and them
entering directly into
mmis 41.3 million has been paid um
through our mmis system for non- Area
Agency providers and then we made um
about 1.8 million in manual payments for
four providers three of them had area
agencies as trading partners and um so
initially um we had asked for the
paybacks of some of the manual payments
to be to occur by December 31st um but
Melissa um has been working with her
team and the agencies and if an agency
is unable to do that we um are extending
yeah I'm still having a hard time
understanding why if these were monies
that were owed to them they have to pay
them
back good afternoon uh Nathan white CFO
um so I I will answer your question in a
circulatory way but I promise I will
answer your question so I I think it's
important to point out that so as Chris
was saying as of October 23rd about $107
million has been paid out if you look at
the budget that our our our budget for
this area is almost $370
million so we are spending along the
lines of the budget so when I I don't I
I I can't I wasn't here previously so I
can't comment necessarily on what was
said relative to that um but it does
appear based on the dollars that are
going out the door right now that we are
in line with the budget as a legislature
appropriated it um the the the pay
payback methodology so because of some
of the challenges with um with the I
believe it's called the echo Vantage
system um that that that's the area
agency system it's not a state system
because because of some of the
challenges what we had to do was we had
the area agencies provide the estimated
numbers and so we made payments on those
estimated numbers and then there's a
Reconciliation process so that we would
make sure that there was no Gap in
funding to avoid that Financial duress
situ situation that that I believe was
described at the prior hearing and so as
part of that we're working on a
methodology to get those funds back um
through through you know through
withholding or whatever it may be um to
make sure that you know everybody is
whole all the funds that went out the
door are accounted for and to try to um
try to alleviate any stress that that
can be alleviated as we go through this
organizational change which you know I
think is important to recognize and
that's part of the reason why why the
team and the commissioner met uh with
the area agencies to go over that
methodology um to to achieve that goal
so
yeah representative
Merchant thank you madam chair and thank
you Mr White for being
here is it simplistically by saying it
correctly to the agenes S of prepaid for
rendered the the payments were made
based on the estimates that that we were
provided so yes so there's a
Reconciliation process that will'll
follow but yes thank you okay yes
representative Weber followup just just
a follow up on that so what is being
payments I I I don't know if I would
describe it as or characterize it as
overpayments but it's essentially to
make sure that if there were any overpay
if there were any overpayments that the
state is due the money that it's owed
right but you you understand why I'm I'm
confused here because
either it was an estimated payment for
services rendered and if the services
were in fact rendered nothing should be
paid
back or it was an overpayment for
services that have not been rendered in
which case it's perfectly Fair to ask
for a
payback but if it isn't a
payback then and it is payment for
services rendered then I don't
understand why the agencies have to pay
anything
back and I know I'm being stupid here
but it's not making sense yeah no again
this was a stop Gap effort to make sure
that given the system challenges and the
bill the billing challenges that were
being experienced that that those could
be rectified so we provided estimates
and some of those estimates May they're
estimates they now they may not actually
be actuals um and and so I believe the
date set for for for many was was
shooting for December 31st um right now
we may not necessarily get there it may
be January February time frame if if not
longer depending on the circumstances um
for for that for that payback Chris what
did you want to add something no just we
have sorry we're juggling here I think
the other piece to um recognize in the
whole reconciliation process is that we
have our own federal reporting to CMS
that we have to account for um the
providers doing a billing for the
service and so this stock Gap allowed us
to give them an estimated payment
without having um a billing completed so
we have to reconcile on our end as well
saying yes these Services were rendered
the billing was completed in our system
um and so that's the other reason why
it's kind of a a payout and a
payback so it is a
payback when they're paying back it's
paying back for an overpayment made for
services that were not because they've
builded for the service yes
okay representative
Nel thank you madam chairman thanks for
taking my question I'm I I'm confused
also I guess I think so I I've had a
number of conversations with agency and
and they've informed me that they're
having to dig into savings some of them
have them some of them don't have them
um and that they're really struggling
financially so the impression that I'm
getting is that they're not being
reimbursed for the services that are
being provided and on number four on
page two here it says you
know that um the title is how much has
been paid compared to what's been buil
I'm seeing a number that's been paid but
I don't know what's been build and they
equal or is I I don't want to answer
but I think it it's because we don't
necessarily know we know that of what
has been build about 177% has been
denied um but I don't know uh exactly
what's been built follow um yes follow
up so by Deni you mean are we getting to
the prior authorization
that's no it's us a data entry error or
it could have been a duplicate claim
it's denied at the
mmis and my light may have finally gone
on is the issue that the prepayment was
made by the
department in anticipation of sums that
were to be paid by someone other than
the department so the department needs
to get the Department's funds back
once Medicaid has paid what they're
supposed to pay is that how it works is
problem that we've got two different
pockets and have to get everything
coming ultimately out of the correct
pocket right in order for us to get our
you know our federal matching dollars we
need the claiming and the billing to be
done in mismis so giving that payment
that estimated payment is not based on
any of those claims um so in order for
us to be able to get that Federal match
through Medicaid we those billing claims
to be done through mmis and not a
prepayment
gotcha and to answer the question
Melissa and her team have been working
with agencies that are unable to pay
that back um and extending
times okay thank you and I'll start
again but I want other people to have
okay I'm going to ask one question
before I
represent recognize somebody else I see
that you have the amount that are paid
and the amount that are denied how many
of these claims are still pending how
what's the dollar value of the pending
claims I don't have that um we can find
that information for you but it's goes
into mmis and it's either paid or denied
um I think are you asking about service
authorizations that may be pending uh no
thank you I this is the first that I
have heard of something that as soon as
it goes in it's either paid or denied as
opposed to there being a processing time
how long is a process in time between
submitting the claim and either approval
or denial because I'm curious how what
the dollar figure is whether that's a
one- day lag or a 15-day lag or a three
Monon lag that's what I'm trying to
understand because that's one of those
cash flow issues that comes based on the
time to I don't have the mmis schedule
here in front of us but we can get you
that information typically it's I I
don't want to estimate thank you because
that may be one of the discrepancies
between what's actually paying out
what's expected and that may be
something that we may not have
identified as a challenge U
representative
Merchant thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking the
question I think this is probably for Mr
White it helps me understanding that it
sounds like it's really a cash flow
issue between the state and the FEDS to
a c some degree and at that point in
time a question I think before you folks
collectively
individually if we miss the December
31st reconciliation between the fed and
the state which deals with the matching
grants and so forth can we take activity
in one quarter and roll it over to the
next quarter as within a fiscal year or
is the December 31st a hard fast rule
that if something's not reconciled on
December 31st but the activity occurred
in October but the bills didn't actually
come in what I'm trying to get to is
trying to understand when you're giving
a prepayment
that's not paid for a service that's
based upon anticipation of a service but
the federal government's only going
reimbursed based upon actual not what's
anticipated but the actual anticipation
I'm looking from a cash flow point of
view if something happens in a
prepayment in October but you don't have
a bill to reconcile with the feds until
after December 31st can you still do it
in
January yeah so when when the department
um
initially met with the area agencies to
come up with this solution December was
a goal and if it needs to move into
January or February I think that's
perfectly fine I think where we would um
collectively start to get into a bit of
trouble is if we approach State fiscal
year end I I think that that's where we
would have some serious problems I'm
hoping we can get everything resolved
long before that time but again December
was the initial tentative goal based on
what seemed appropriate at that time um
I again as Chris stated at the beginning
I think we're collectively committed to
making sure that this that this works um
and so if if one Area Agency can't
necessarily get to that December 31st
date then we will work with them and and
Melissa and her team have been meeting
with area agencies that have voiced
their concerns um relative to any cash
flows to work out a solution towards
towards a a a
ending you follow up thank you one thing
we talked about last time we
met is that sometimes it comes within
the department itself is the need to
move money from one line to another line
temporarily and that has to go to the
fiscal committee is there any
requirement in your opinion now that we
have to go to the fiscal committee to
ask for some lency from the fiscal
committee to allow the department to
move money from from one bucket to
another while we work our way through
this no this is all paid out of class
7100 and you have one over there oh
fantastic representative
Nel thank you madam chairman this is
very simple when's your fiscal year
end June 30th what I thought thank
you representative
Weber okay so now I'm going to go off on
another tack if I may yeah um thank you
for all of this because it is
complicated and we are learning and it's
important for us to have a better
understanding but it seems to me that we
are talking about apples and oranges
here I mean on the one hand there is the
cash flow issue that it is important for
all of us to understand and perhaps to
monitor going forward in which case we
have several mechanisms including the
Health and Human Services oversight
committee or possibly an ad hoc
Committee of Health and Human Services
either of which could do that work but
we also have a bill in front of us and
what we're here today to decide is what
to do about that bill and what I'm
hearing from you is everything that's in
the bill you already can do what I hear
from some people is we want to make darn
sure it's done so we want to put it into
statute um
and I think what what we're here for
today is to make a decision on whether
we are going to pass this or not so
um
I haven't heard anything that sounds
like the department will come to a
screeching halt if we pass this and I
have heard of a lot of people who would
be more comfortable if we pass this
understanding that it doesn't actually
help with the problem we've just been
starting about except that it might keep
us out of a new one somewhere down the
line so I'm I'm hoping that as soon as
everybody's satisfied with the question
I don't want to stop anybody from
getting a full understanding because I
think it's very important uh but I'm I'm
just hoping that we all refocus
ourselves to the language of the bill as
soon as that's finished so thank you
representative Weber um I think that one
of the other questions regarding the
staging and this planning and the
necessity to Pilot something to roll out
smaller than to the whole state um
that's relevant is a question on the
billing integration to the mmis system
and how much visibility was provided to
the area agencies and everybody else who
would be direct billing so that they
could have a system online and ready to
go July 1st so that they could integrate
and not run into issues of having to
manually bill or otherwise request funds
provided thank you for the question I
think um from the Department standpoint
we worked closely with Area Agency
specifically um but also with providers
as far as what this may look like and
you know I'm not here to say that it
worked 100% smoothly on the Department's
uh part as far as data
conversion um service authorization
issues I I I'm not claiming that that
was 100% an A+ um and we've said that to
our providers and area agencies what I
do think is that um on both ends there
were glitches as far as um our data
conversion um the ability for the area
agencies themselves to bill with their
software that they were using or are
using um and still having that inability
in in some cases to bill so um I think
we were visible very visible I think
we're still um working in Partnership to
we have one-on-one meetings with
providers to work through whether it's a
service authorization issue whether it's
an mismis issue whether it's a
remittance issue and we're taking that
one by one with each provider um in
order to figure out from a from a
uh where the roadblock is is that there
in software is it us is it our service
authorizations that need to be updated
so I would say that we've certainly been
U very visible and um available to
anyone that asks or needs
assistance thank you and I just to
follow up you know mismis that's what
all Medicaid providers use to Bill and
um you know some providers build
directly depending on how many claims
they have others use trading partners
others have their own billing software
um so the mmis system is not a new
system um so usually my role in new it
roll outs is to be an early user because
I'm really good at breaking stuff but
because I'm generally their great
breaking user um a lot of times I've
talked with it departments and usually
they end up having some sort of scope
and some sort of set of information
about what they need to integrate into
um and I know that I can't ask for that
right now but if you could provide any
documentation that you provided to the
area agencies and those doing their own
direct billing about what their systems
needed in specific so that they would be
ready to launch and integrate with the
MMS mmis system that would be helpful
and I know that this seems like sort of
an an after action trying to figure out
what happened but the question also is
going forward you know I know I've been
accused of springing things on people
the last minute as I handed some of
these out um but this this is different
than making sure that people are able to
bill for millions of dollars of money to
provide care um to have an idea of how
how it was handled with this integration
so we can get an idea of sort of what
the process has been and how and how
necessary it is to continue on making
sure that there's not just your eyes who
are focused in at ground level on the
implementation but a few people that can
fly over on the surveillance drones and
spot something that you're not able to
see because I expect that your
Department's experiencing the same
staffing issues as everybody else is
that something that would be available
that you could make
available yes I think um all of our um
work groups are generally posted and and
online on YouTube so we can certain it
might take us a little bit to get that
to you but we certainly can pull any
trainings or meetings that we had had as
it relates to how that billing piece
would work um thank you and more
specifically it would be any document
that went out because discussing the
general principles doesn't help you to
purchase a system that will allow you to
bill um and and then um sorry any were
there other questions representative
Merchant oh sorry and co- calleded after
Merchant wanted to follow thank you for
the
question Mr mam chair following up on
represent Weber looking at the
bill I don't think I'm hearing much of
an issue from the Department's point of
view as far as this bill interfering
with what you need to
accomplish I do understand from the
provider's point of view that there are
concerns sometimes along the way and
sometimes when you have two parties if
you will in this case multiple parties
and one part is saying yes it will work
one part saying no it won't work and so
forth it's a difficult place to
be we're fortunate because in the
legislative body we do have an oversight
committee and maybe the option would be
that when you have a situation and maybe
it's a report coming back before you
move on to the next phase that you go to
the oversight committee and they sign
off on it and it gives them they've been
the other people on the other side of
providers an opportunity to come to the
oversight committee and discuss the
concerns so at that point in time you
have the agency on one side that says
yes it's a green light the other one
said well I think it's more of a yellow
light but there's somebody the will to
act that sort of an arbitrator to listen
to what the concerns are and ultimately
make a decision to move forward or not
I I actually think that may be more
feasible than a pilot and then
legislation for a pilot using either the
existing oversight committee because I
one of the concerns I would have is if
you know we do testing we get ready to
go and we don't necessarily need a pilot
or it's the rates for the dsps which
many providers need so we we don't want
any of the work to get held up um but if
there's a way that we could go to either
a subcommittee of this committee or
oversight committee I'm not sure that
maybe would make more
sense like to follow I me I I like the
concern the concept of a subcommittee
because sometimes it gets relatively
into the weeds and when you get to the
oversight committee there's so much
going on with the oversight committee
they may not have the time to put into
it that needs to be put into it so maybe
a sub Committee of this committee would
make more sense not that I want to
create more work but I think at that
point in time is take it out of the
bigger picture and bring it into
something really focus on what this
issue
is thank you representative
kofalt uh thank you madam chair and um I
guess I just want to it's it's comments
more than questions at this point
um there was some discussion about sort
of getting some visibility to what's
happened in the past I'm not so
concerned about what's happened in the
past I want to I'm concerned about
what's happened in in the future or
what's going to happen in the future and
that we continue services and so what
I've heard is that you're going to focus
on compliance and um you you essentially
have a a a kind of road map for Rolling
the you
know stabilizing the plan going forward
I think that that's what's
necessary
um when the chair opened the session uh
you used the the phrase support how can
the legislature support you
and that we need to be observant um I
guess my concern
about a pilot program at this point is
that we're sort of beyond that point we
need I think we need to be concerned
about
the the unintended effects of of putting
things in
statute um that that are that
prescriptive on the other hand I would I
would I would Echo representative
Merchant's comments that I I think this
is
important enough that it calls for a
kind of focused attention and not
something that is on the agenda with a
bunch of other things uh with the the um
DHHS oversight committee um so
personally I would be very strongly in
favor of of kind of a subcommittee of
the Health and Human Services committee
to be continuing to monitor progress
going forward but um I guess my concern
is that you know we have we have the
division between the executive branch
and the legislative function for for
reason and
um as much as I think it's important for
us to
be ensuring that that we can continue
delivering these
Services I'm I'm a little bit concerned
about legislation that continues to say
You must have a pilot program
um so so that's my my general comment
um the other the other concern I have is
I know that because the department has
worked with um with the area agencies
and essentially has said we we'll step
in to solve the cash flow problem until
things are are more
stable I think that there is some fear
and anxiety around the repayment
schedule for that or that's what I've
been hearing anyway and I've also heard
that the department is working with
those area agencies to make sure that
those kinds of concerns get resolved yet
I'm still I still heard those concerns
so I guess that that's maybe there maybe
there's a question in there that is is
there anything that we can do to sort of
match the the repayment schedule with
the incoming funds that that come to the
agencies for for the from from the
mismis
building yes thank you for that comment
um we are working one-on-one with area
agencies looking at their ability to
Bill what they're taking in from billing
versus you know their cash flow needs to
meet meet payroll um to meet their
weekly or monthly expenses so we've met
with several area agencies on either
pausing the repayment schedule for now
until they can bill out an amount that
keeps them solvent um or um you know
looking at a different percentage of a
repayment so as the area agencies come
to us we are meeting with them oneon-one
to determine what's best for their
business for from their perspective okay
follow up yes follow up um
is there anything that can be done to
make that a little bit
more um predictable I'll say because
that the the concern I'm hearing is that
well yes we can go ask for an extension
but
there's it it's hard to it's hard to
forecast cash flow based on ad hoc
conversations that come up so I guess
that's and I don't expect that there's
necessarily going to be an answer coming
out of this discussion today because I
think that's requires some more research
and planning but that's something that
I've heard and I guess that would be
a a question to you is that something
that you can look into and consider the
feasibility of sure thank
you representative
Weber so following up on what
representative kofalt said um I am very
much in agreement with most of what he
said and and here's my concern with the
proposal from representative
Merchant uh I'm
very concerned I I mean I think I think
we may have moved past the Pilot Point
in which
case
um the changes I think proposed by
representative Lon for page one lines 3
to7 are actually very helpful because
it's already kind of in train but
perhaps we might not need to be as
directive as what's in paragraph to uh
which is very
directive um and you
know two and three are very directive so
I'm I'm wondering about whether we need
to do some noodling around with that and
making them less directive but what I'm
also concerned about I share very much
the concern about simply reporting to
the Health and Human Services oversight
committee which is snowed under with
reports at the moment
uh but the concept of having an
executive department report and
be potentially blocked from action by a
subcommittee of a legislative
committee uh begins to give me hives
from the dimly recollected days of my
law school proceedings where uh we
really
are getting away from the concept that I
understand about separation of powers so
and and I I would be very concerned
everybody in this room is a person of
very good will but delegating that kind
of power to a subcommittee of a
committee
feels risky for the future um in terms
of wow do we want to start having little
subcommittees that can block or overrule
an executive
agency going forward so that that makes
me very concerned if we have a
subcommittee that actually the purpose
of which is to continue this dialogue
which I think is very
productive um then that would not I
would be very much in favor of that I'm
I'm a little anxious when we say that
either Health and Human Services
oversight or a subcommittee of some kind
can actually hold up
the actions of the
department um you know what what we're
really trying to do is help the
department move the actions forward
faster rather than than slow them down
so those are my concerns with sort of
the stuff I've heard so far um and
I I really wonder if we might not be
able to resolve this by not heading
forward with the bill at all
but by making a recommendation to Health
and Human Services that we set up some
kind of a subcommittee to hear from the
Department regular intervals about how
things are going forward because on on
the one hand I don't see that the
piloting
requirements are really relevant to
where we are now um but on the other
hand I think that understanding what's
happening going forward and and perhaps
being able to nudge things when nudges
are needed is really helpful so that's
I'm I I've changed my position on all of
this at least four times since I walked
in this morning but I I wonder how how
that's feeling to people uh thank you
representative Weber I have a question
um about the Staffing levels of the
department do you have empty positions
um have those begun since the change
over so I can speak on uh behalf of the
Bureau of Developmental services so we
currently have two key positions that
are vacant that we're recruiting for so
a bureau chief and a chief operating
officer so two positions that you know
are key to the work um but we have
really dedicated staff that has been um
on this project before I even started
that department about two years ago that
um have been working tirelessly on this
so while we do have two key openings um
we have dedicated staff to this
project um and Nathan will talk broader
but I also want to say and I think
that's some of the reason why um we also
agree with some of the pausing and
delaying any other work um so that our
staff can catch up as well so that they
can you know kind of make sure
everything from the compliance is good
before we do anything new recognizing
their limitations as well and um
speaking uh from a broad perspective in
December of 2022 or 20 yes 2022 we had a
22% vacancy rate um we have been able to
make a lot of progress on that last um
report I saw we were hovering around
18% vacancy rate um part of that was due
to the prior year we had a Personnel
back of the budget cut of 22.6 million
um this year we do have a back of the
budget cut it's not targeted at
personnel only
um and to date that has freed us up and
allowed us to recruit a little bit more
aggressively than we have in the past um
so in almost a year we've seen a 5%
vacancy drop which I I think globally is
fantastic um but I'll pause there okay
um and thank you for for that I guess
it's not our job to be in your hiring
but I'm I wonder if it might be easier
if there's people that deserve to be
promoted within and then recruit for the
other positions it might be a good thing
to think of yeah we always start um
within um and then go from there
wonderful that seems to be the least
disruptive especially when they know
what's going on representative
Merchant thank you madam
chair like reps the Weber I vacillate
between the roles
that I do respect and appreciate the
separation of powers and the roles that
we both play however I'm also looking at
it from a pragmatic point of view that
if there's an agencies out there in a
state
fundamentally the agency holds all the
cards there's the whether the agencies
that you're dealing with like it or not
it's your call all I'm trying to do is
find a vehicle that we can allow for
both sides of the fence to have a
conversation sort of maybe a neutral
body although according to the lawyers
that's not so neutral as I thought it
would be but I think it means there be
some safety valve in there if there's a
sounding board that people can go to and
people can at that point in time make
sort of a judgment call whether they
should go forward or not go forward I'm
not saying that you wouldn't be allowed
to go forward because ultimately you're
executive branch and you can do as you
wish because that's the way the law was
written however I think if you have a
subcommittee that you're responsible to
before you move forward it probably be
be in your best interest to be sure
things are Ved correctly before you move
forward against the advice of the
agencies or maybe the advice of the
legisl
body thank you representative Merchant
um that's actually one of the reasons
why I think that continuing along with
this while perhaps having that
subcommittee may be helpful because the
subcommittee may be able to speak to the
Senate as they're hearing the bill and
see if there is if there are any
necessary changes or if this was
required U my understanding when you
were discussing the change out to the
rate setting was that you're essentially
going to be doing a pilot program by
triing this with some providers is that
correct
so we're we're working with Myers and
stoffer and have been um throughout this
process and looking at rates um based on
in cost information that we're receiving
um we have not developed a pilot so to
speak as far as what the that would look
like as we don't have the rates yet we
don't know what the fiscal impact looks
like um to test those rates so um if we
were to do and again working with the
area agencies and and the providers that
provide the services we would want to do
some sort of testing of those rates to
see if they're viable um or if we need
to course correct but we're we're not
even at that point yet as we don't have
draft rates um for the the entirety of
our service delivery okay so to clarify
that once you know what the draft rates
are you would roll it out to a subset of
the population and not Statewide well
that that would be part of our
discussion with our setting group as far
as what does that testing look like does
it look like for a specific service does
it look like for a specific um entity um
so we haven't defined that because we
just haven't gotten to that place yet
but that would be a discussion that we
have with our rate setting group that
includes stakeholders as far as are
there certain service Service rates we
want to trial um to see if they uh make
a a service more intriguing for a
provider to provide um and and what does
that look like as far as Workforce
Development as well okay so with that
either Regional or targeted based upon
certain codes correct exactly yep thank
you um and then with the electronic
visit verification we're a rural state
with bad cell coverage uh is this one
that you all I know that this is
federally required is this something
that you're planning to sort of run
parallel as you integrate the first
adoption and see if it's viable um and
then see if there needs to be any
requests to DC to change the
requirements or are you planning on a
Statewide roll out when you do move
forward with the
evv um so evv can you hear me it doesn't
sound like the microphone's on evv is
larger than BDS it is um Medicaid home
health services and personal care
services and so there's been a lot of
work um with all so Home Health
Providers um choices for Independence
providers it's it's a large um
undertaking and so they are working with
stakeholders and working with the it
it's been extended a couple of times and
right now the roll out is March and
that's another compliance issue and we
have been paying fines up to this point
state and and just to give a little bit
of context for personal care services to
date we've about a million dollar um
back to the federal government that you
haven't really seen a big impact um on
our budget though because we've been
receiving the enhanced fmap rate um so
instead of getting the 6 point
additional 6.2 we've effectively been
getting a 5.2 however come January 1 of
2024 all- enhanced fmap will be leaving
so um for personal care services we'll
be paying about $140,000 in penalties um
we have a waiver for home healthcare
Services up until January 1
2024 um uh quarterly we'll be paying
about
$28,000 in 20 in state fiscal year 24
it's not too much um but that
essentially will um uh the the 0.25%
penalty we're paying it'll increase to
0.575 and then 1% um so by 2027 if we're
still not in compliance at that point
for Home Healthcare Services it'll be
about
$112,000 annually if you adjust for um
utilization that'll probably a little
higher so uh collectively in four years
I mean we could be playing about 250,000
or more each quarter in penalties for
not being in
compliance um thank you um and I guess
that also brings us back to the issue of
waivers um we're a small state we have
about the I I'm not sure when I last did
the math but we have about the footprint
of San Diego County with about the
population of um some some lines you can
draw around the city of San Diego um
other states like California which holds
that are able to push back against some
of the federal requirements when it's
not a good fit with waivers um and I've
seen some of those waivers in place that
New Hampshire was unsuccessful about
pushing for our own waivers um I'm
curious what the process is and the
decisions are around pushing not just
for waivers of extension but simply
waivers because the prescription that's
coming from DC doesn't fit the reality
of how care is provided in New Hampshire
and who's in charge of those decisions
so I will have to reach out to our
Medicaid director Henry Litman um
because this is work that he's been
doing I do know that New Hampshire um
did have a good faith exemption that
expires um in December January 1st so we
can follow up with Henry if there was
any other exemptions and get back to you
okay um thank you then as a followup um
did that does that mean that the
decision about whether or not to pursue
a waiver resided with Henry Lipman or
did it reside with somebody within the
department to ultimately not pursue
another
extension well Henry Works within our
department so yeah so I'll I'll follow
up with Henry on that so he is the one
who made the decision not to proceed in
a waiver no um it's a collective
decision at the department so I'll
follow up with Henry on the details of
that okay I'd love to know who's
involved so I can speak with them some
more thank
you representative
Weber so to get back to the bill what
are we going to do with the
bill and I had another
thought even while we were
talking which
is perhaps the thing to do with the
bill is to refer it to interim study and
properly interim study it by having a
meeting every couple of months to see
where we are with it as as we have every
right to
do um and that will give the
committee the ongoing dialogue going
forward without putting what may turn
out to be a roadblock in somebody's way
so I wonder how committee members would
feel about that as an
option um thank you representative
kofalt um I I think that's an excellent
idea um before we move on to a decision
I don't know if there are other
stakeholders in the room who want an
opportunity to speak though so I so my
my initial reaction is I I like that
that proposal quite a lot uh but I'd
like to hear from others if there are
others here um thank you I think that's
a very intriguing idea um we actually um
we're now a little bit after 2 o'clock
and I know that the department had
penciled Us in for 1 to two um I would
hope that before we hear the other
stakeholders we could recess this work
session and open up 317 so we could ask
some important questions from the
department on that so with that I will
uh recess our work session on House Bill
608 you have to recess it to a Time
certain so res uh to to 2:30 or
something like that I I'll recess it
until 2:30 um and if we run over on 317
a little bit then we can figure that out
okay um so I'll recess it until 2:30
today we can then start it again late
but yes we can well if we can start it
late let's recess it to h i yeah 2:30
works that way we can get some water
thank
you
okay yes I think it's probably better to
stay sitting there I will open the work
session on House Bill
317 um 317 is establishing a commission
to study the transition to a two tier
waiver for individuals eligible for
disability services um as far as I'm
concerned the largest question here is
when is that expected to happen and is
that going to be undertaken before we
get through all of these other changes
to the system
so do I have to Chris santinello
associate commissioner I'm not sure if I
have to if it's a different
committee Melissa hery division director
for long-term supports and services so
um about May of 2022 the department we
signaled and shared that we would not be
moving forward with a two-tiered waiver
and and not even looking at it
until later 2023 early 2024 and honestly
it is not even on our radar um so that's
not something um that we
have you know I kind of like think about
you know it's it's not anything we're
looking to pursue right now um I know
there's a number of changes to our
existing waiver there's been a waver
subgroup looking at and I think um
that's where we want to start
strengthening our existing waiver before
even looking at a two- teed waiver so
it's it's not on any
plans and I I just want to add that we
we paused any sort of work on that to
tiered waiver based on the feedback that
we were received from the stakeholders
and families just questioning you know
why why would we do this now um you know
what this is what does this mean as far
as services for me and my family and so
since we announced back last year in May
that we weren't doing any you know work
on it we weren't even going to dust it
off until maybe at the end of this
fiscal year we have not um done any work
on developing a two-tier waiver system
so it's it's it's not on our radar to to
complete um thank you would what would
trigger it to come onto your radar would
that be completion of of the current
waiver re-evaluation and these other
Integrations I think that would be part
of it but I also think getting the input
from individuals and families and
providers as far as is it something that
they would want or they would see as a
benefit um to the services that they
provide um so I think that would be
another trigger in looking at it again
it would wouldn't be something that we
could even Implement without you know a
a CMS waver change and and all of those
steps so it's not it's not something
that we can do quickly or easily and
wouldn't do without you know significant
input from the community large so
timeline wise looking at everything
you're looking to digest would I assume
that you wouldn't be taking this up
probably until
2026 just given that there are so many
challenges and we're practically in 2024
now I would agree with that yes
representative Nagel thank you madam
chairman thanks for taking my question
so my understanding now is the way that
you deal with patients is on a Case by
case patient centered point of view
rather than lumping people into
categories yes I would say um you know
individual needs are measured by you
know integration with their case
management with their family with
themselves um as far as their individual
service agreement um but I think I think
you're getting to the point where people
thought you were in one tier and maybe
if you at a lower tier you needed less
or more um and we don't want to create a
system where we have you know folks that
are perceived as being haves or Have
Nots and I think that was a lot of the
feedback that we received from um the
community as far as when you're looking
at putting people in
buckets I guess I have a followup yes
follow up yeah this this issue always
really troubled me I mean everything
that I've dealt with since I've gotten
here we we've really stressed dealing
with patients as individ or I'm sorry
patients clients people
individuals you know and a patient
centered point of view with their own
individual needs and I really struggled
with this concept of a tiered
system just defying that and and that
bothered me a lot I understand from a
dollars and cents point of view it might
have made sense but from a human point
of view it really didn't um I'm
still struggling with this concept when
I read the the report though it it
talked about multiple tiers not just a
two or a three and I'm still confused
why a two would have even been picked
versus a three because they gave
recommendations for both um I mean the
Le the more tiers the better as far as
I'm concerned but why why would his two-
tiered even picked in the first
place I can see the recommendation from
a cons our consultant would have been
people who you know require a higher
level of care whether that's Residential
Care um you know if they required
one-on-one supports which um cost
obviously more than folks that may need
a lower level of Assistance or services
in the community so kind of looking at
those two um separate tiers but I I
think we agree with you as far as you
know um even putting people in three
tiers there's still you know bucketing
of individuals and we really want to
make it a whole person approach thank
you representative
Weber and
just sort of echoing and following on
from what representative Nagel was
saying it seems to me that the thing
that people were
particularly pleased with and
comfortable with was the
flexibility that has been traditionally
available and I think anything we can do
to preserve that
because
um you
it's people and and nobody's going to
have the same set of needs they just
aren't built that way so the more
flexibility we can build
in to any system going forward the
better and locking people into a tier
feels really wrong that brings me to the
question and you can all sing the chus
with me what are we going to do with
this
bill uh because it seems to me in many
ways like having a commission to study
something that is not contemplated going
forward is probably not a good use of
anybody's time but once again I don't
want to lose sight of the problem or
everybody's attempts to address the
problem uh so I don't want anybody to
think that what we might be doing is
just throwing up our hands and walking
away or sweeping something under the rug
but I don't see this as being
particularly helpful at this point in
time um and and again I would like to
hear from other people on that side of
the table and I I noticed that the prime
sponsor is also here thank you
representative Weber my my biggest
question would be is does is the
department comfortable in saying that
they will not they're not that they are
that they're not they're that they're
not going to start work on a two-tier um
waiver system until after 2026 at the
soonest yeah I think we can definitely
say that um we actually have a very
active w we had an very active waiver
work group to look at adding more
flexibilities and services to our
existing waivers um so that's really
where our energy has been and will be so
this will not happen before 2026 that's
incredibly help
um my thought would be that um I'd love
to listen to more any more input from
anybody who's here around this but given
um that confidence that the Department's
not going to move forward on that before
2026 I would think that this would make
sense to itl it so um thank you very
much for being here and thank you for
staying later to be able to get us the
information I expect we'll be seeing
more of each other just to make sure
that everybody's confident in how this
process continues to move forward thank
you thank
you
okay um I wanted to see if there's
anybody else who wanted to speak to us
before we take a vote um would you like
representative uh Jerry Stringham uh
State Rep from Lincoln New Hampshire um
basically from what I heard you know
when this when this bill was submitted
uh the the working uh plan was the the
uh recommendation from the Alvarez and
Marcelo report were to be implemented
actually by now so there and there was
no understanding really of uh how the
groups would be divided and what Ser
Services would be limited how providers
would be uh what services that they were
used to being able to prescribe were now
going to be off limits for some uh for
some beneficiary so there was a lot of
lot of work to do um to understand that
and there was concerns there would be
massive unintended consequences if this
was implemented um as far as I'm
concerned um that uh you know we don't
need a commission if uh nothing is going
to change or we're going to focus on the
other changes that are going on uh you
know over the next two and a half years
so um uh there was certainly um
everybody I talked to from the
beneficiary side didn't say it was
necessarily a bad idea they just didn't
understand what would look like and what
the consequences would be um there's
plenty of willingness to participate in
something like that it sounds like uh
the department is going towards more
flexibility uh in empowering uh the case
managers and others to um be able to
tailor the services more not limit them
as a two-tiered waiver system might have
so uh I don't have any issue with iing
this bill based on uh where where BDS is
uh gone in the last last year or so so
thank you are there any questions from
this no thank you very much um is there
anybody else who yes Mr
kbis Alex kis
microphone my name is Alex kbis with
Denny and ble I represent the Community
Support Network which is the association
of the tary agencies uh we actually
asked representative Stringham to file
this piece of legislation and we greatly
thank him for being here this afternoon
and continuing to follow through on this
and it really uh the request came uh for
the simple reason that the the
recommendation for this two there's two
or three or however many tier waiver
system it it it will become was made
without families providers at the table
uh we were never saying that we were
going to shut the door completely on
this but it needs a tremendous amount
more study more involvement from the
participants in the syst system the
providers of the services the workers in
the system and obviously from the
previous bill you you understand that
now is not the time to be changing a
waiver that was put in place I believe
in 1983 so that'd be about 40 years it's
it's worked well a lot of people depend
on that waiver it's uh brought in
obviously a tremendous amount of federal
dollars and provided some unique and
Innovative services that keep people in
their Community which is where the
majority of them uh want to be so uh
certainly itl it's fine it's clear it's
it's probably not moving forward anytime
soon and uh I think the bill has
accomplished uh what we needed to which
is to put a spotlight on the issue slow
it down a little bit have a conversation
with our elected officials so we thank
the department for uh changing course on
this and again thank you and and
representative Stringham for your uh
advocacy for your
constituents thank you very much and
thanks for being here both at the
previous hearing and now this work
session thank you you're welcome is
there anybody else okay thank you I I
have I think we're ready for a v vote if
anybody wants to make a
motion representative Weber I would move
itl with thanks to everybody involved
for the dialogue that this bill has
promoted because we have talked about it
probably more than a commission would
have by by now and and that has been
very productive and it's also been an
education I think for all of us on this
side of the table so would move
itl second you second that
representative n is somebody who became
a u client of the services as of
yesterday morning I really appreciate
here um thank you then I will call a
vote representative Nagel yes okay
representative kofalt yes representative
Weber yes oh sorry I think I pulled the
wrong one but so far I'm at the correct
so far you're still okay yes I saw the
um representative n upam yes and
representative Le on yes so that would
be 50 itl on house bille 317 um and so I
will close the work we'll recommend that
to the full committee and I will close
the work session on 37 we have about 7
minutes if we start on time for 6:08 so
everybody can perfect take care of
moment thank
mics
it's just after 2:30 so if we can move
people back to their seats we can go
back to our regularly scheduled
programming representative
okay okay um and I do know that uh
sometimes sometimes it uh takes more
than a moment to take a break so um I we
probably should go ahead and get started
seeing who else there is to hear from
um yes yes
sir so if you can come up and introduce
yourself to the committee I guess I'm
officially reopening the work session on
good afternoon U my name is Robert
Gillis I live in Hancock New Hampshire
um and I'd like to thank the committee
members for allowing me this chance to
speak on House Bill 608 um I work I'm
the executive director for madn
WorkSource um we're a small provider of
Disability Services located in the badok
region uh we've been delivering
Disability Services since 19 1971 and
just celebrated our 52nd year in
existence um we're an incredibly flat
small entity there's myself I have an
administrative assistant four program
managers and 23 direct staff who provide
services for 34 individuals throughout
the madok region um and this process has
in some ways um been paralyzing for me
as an executive director um because we
don't have a finance department we don't
have a billing department we never knew
what mmis looked like or even meant
because our area agency always took care
of that billing for us and so um I've
had to dedicate probably 70 to 75% of my
time since July 1st on trying to get our
agency through the changes that have
occurred because of um you know yes the
man the
mandated CMS rules um but um I would
like to again go back and forth on
whether I support uh of um the bill
itself but um to me as a small entity I
attended all of the trainings that were
offered by BDS I attended every meeting
I could possibly be involved in um and
we are still um truly suffering
financially um and just with me being
able to focus on the rest of my job um
because I've had to dedicate so much of
my time to trying to see where our
Billings at trying to investigate where
the problems are whether it's with
service um authorizations whether it's
with my managers and what they've build
um whether it's been with the third
party biller that we've signed up with
um
small businesses are the heart of New
Hampshire's economy and you know
testimony that we've heard so far today
you know really talks about the area
agency and the provider agencies and
from the tables that I've sat around and
conquered when I've been part of some of
these Endeavors um a lot of the agencies
are of the size of Easter Seals um yes
they're providers but um it's hard to
have a voice as a a small provider in
the state and we're by no means the
smallest providers um again we support
34 individuals um our revenues for our
services are about $1.8
million um but there are many agencies
that are much smaller than ours um and
to me a pilot program would have
eliminated many of the things that I had
to learn kind of on my own after July
1st um and so I I would like to suggest
that there is close scrutiny whether it
be a pilot program um because again the
heart of our economy here in New
Hampshire and a big part of our
disability delivery system is small
providers like madn work Shores and we
are truly struggling um we have gotten
good billing um we have had money coming
in but um I am worried about us making
our payroll in another week I actually
just emailed back and forth with Melissa
earlier today to try to find a way to
possibly have access to some of the
funds that they've talked about um
because our billing has not been
consistent and actually recently it
seems to have gotten worse as far as the
service authorizations being done on
time and properly um and my ability as
an overwhelmed executive director to
wrap my brain around where the problem
is with our bill
um the mmis system is archaic and
Incredibly complicated and has been very
very difficult um certainly for myself
to incorporate into our our daily
function so and thank you for the time
thank you and thank you for your service
to everybody and the amount of time that
you spent providing services to people
in New Hampshire we really thank you um
yeah so I I just have one question as
and then I'll recognize you
representative Weber so you said that
you're spending 70 to 75% of your time
on billing and you're using a third
party biller um on on yes on you know
billing and as far as the mmis system
trying to learn even though we're not
doing the billing ourselves um trying to
understand what all the coding modifiers
mean trying to verify that the numbers
that we're receiving for our unit rates
are what we should be receiving um it
would be nice if we just pushed a button
and our biller did all the billing for
us they've been doing a great Sky great
job one sky here um but making sure that
all of that billing is happening as it
should um is where my energies and time
has gone and trying to then investigate
why we haven't been paid for one of our
individuals for over a month now
um has been a very cumbersome process
thank you and then with that it sounds
like you need to know all the
intricacies of Medicaid billing in order
to pass it off to your third party
biller is that correct exactly yeah
maybe not all of it but 90% of it we
have to understand because we need to
try to help find out why it's not going
through properly um and I'd like to be
proud of my managers it seems like them
submitting their attendance has not been
the bulk of the problem well thank you
and I want to AP my understanding of the
switch to third party billers is that it
would be pretty easy and similar to what
was going on before but it seems that
wasn't the case representative
Weber well I had two things thank you
madam chair and thank you for being here
today taking our questions and doing the
work that you do because it's really
very much
appreciated um I guess just to follow on
what you were saying so the issue for
you is ensuring that you have input to
your biller the proper codes forms
whatever needs to be sent to them so
that they can do the billing going
forward is that
correct again that's where the hard part
is that's one of the components you know
the the bigger component is you know
looking at what mmis has for manad work
source is a printout that's about six
feet long and to try to understand why
that rate isn't what we were expecting
it to be and trying to get to the bottom
of why it's wrong has taken me 152
emails back and forth to the Service
Coordination entities the billing
entities um and our organization to try
to make sure that I can try to get to
the bottom of what needs to be fixed for
our billing to occur properly and just
as a followup and could I just ask you
if if if we were to interim study this
bill and to try and keep an eye on
things going forward I I would just ask
please feel free to contact any of us
but I'm I'm in walpool so I'm in the
manad region and I would love to hear
from you about issues going forward so
we can keep our eye fully on the ball
because I I don't want us to just say
aha we're done as a legislature I want
to keep
great thank you and I going forward so
please do stay in touch thank you I
Brett thank you madam
chair this is sort of post what you're
talking about what was it pre what I'm
trying to understand is that it's sort
of an
analogy before you could simply write
something on a piece of paper s to give
to somebody else who then go to the word
process or Word document whatever it's
going to be Microsoft Word and so forth
and they would create the document for
you by using the
software I mean now all of a sudden you
can't do that you have to understand how
to use Microsoft Word in order to create
the document because you can't simply
just get somebody sort of an invoice but
maybe or simplifying what's there
because what happened pre that changed
Post Yeah we you know again our area
agency um was responsible for doing our
billing previously you know they also
were primarily The Entity that was
responsible for our Service Coordination
so they worked closely together behind
the scenes um and we submitted weekly
attendance sheets that you know noted
the units that we delivered it was a
simple Excel spreadsheet and we gave
that to the area agency and two weeks
later we got a nice little print out by
client that was about 11 pages long as
to what we were paid for each of those
clients um we'd have a similar type of
sheet from one sky that we submit the
the days that our services um were
delivered what our units were um and now
the same printout we get is around 78
pages long um all on individual lines
for individual days for each client and
each of their cost centers and trying to
compare that to what we were expecting
to come in as revenues um is is where
part of our difficulty has been then out
of those the denials that we've had
trying to investigate with the area
agency Service Coordination folks um has
been has been difficult as we have had
difficulties with Workforce I know the
area agencies have difficulties with
Workforce so many of those service
coordinators I know are new to this
whole process as well so they've been
learning you know their role in entering
information into um you know their their
system um and so the paperwork we submit
hasn't changed that much um but it's
making sure that all that billing is
happening happening properly that we're
receiving what we are expecting to
receive and when it's not happening
trying to figure out why it's not
happening has been what a great part of
my burden is and that's only related to
the billing component of this systems
change a big part of the systems change
is also our responsibility as a provider
because there have been many changes
that are part of this July 1st
transition um that has changed the
nature of our role with the area agency
and with service coordinators so I have
to also try to make sure as an agency
you know we're following what our new
expectations um
h504 the the provider regulation um
trying to make sure that we're in
compliance with that that we're
understanding of that um so it's not
solely the billing that's of course
what's most important to me to my board
to being able to pay my staff um not
knowing what the rates are going to be
and you know the Meers and stofer work
um that has you know we were expecting
that initially July of this year and
then we were expecting it of January of
this year and now it's July of next year
um and not having the confidence to know
whether what our rates are going to be
um my board has not allowed me to give
my staff pay raises for a year and a
half because we don't really know what
our revenues are going to be because we
have all of these unanswered questions s
um so it's that whole package that's
taking so much of my time not just the
billing component although that is a a
fairly major component especially for a
small
organization thank you so much for
coming and sharing that um I I'm
expecting that we probably will um
regardless of the outcome of this bill
have a subcommittee of this committee to
sort of see what's going on and I hope
that you'll come and help us exp help us
understand the transition in your role
so that we can understand how the
legislature can support the department
and you and everybody else involved in
this great thank you the small providers
in the state really need a voice and I
will do my best to be available for it
thank you yes that's one of those places
commissions are great to get a lot of
people in but hearings and coming and
speaking and not and just even those
work sessions where the individuals
involved can come and have the same
voice is one of the beauties of the New
Hampshire legislature so thank you
agreed thank you okay um is
yes yes ma'am if you'd like to come
up and if you can introduce yourself
up is it already on it looks on okay yes
um good afternoon I'm Pam Loy executive
director of Great Bay Services we serve
straford and Rockingham counties in the
state of New Hampshire and York and
Cumberland counties in the state of
Maine thank you so much uh Madam
chairwoman and representatives for
allowing me to speak a bit today um Mr
Gillis who you just heard from is one of
my peers on the private providers
Network which is a coalition of uh small
and large providers across the state of
New Hampshire some of us are like Easter
Seals uh very large and serve the entire
State some are relatively small like
manad uh work source for Great Bay
Services we're relatively small and we
do straddle that main New Hampshire line
so our experiences with uh changes that
have been happening in Medicaid is sort
of
multifaceted um I also feel Duty bound
to mention my older brother is also a
service recipient and because of delays
wrapped up in um the
pandemic uh we found him dropped from
Medicaid as of July 13th along with I'm
sure tens of thousands of other new
hampshirites uh a process which should
have really taken nine months uh was
condensed into a very short period and
within the span of about an hour we got
a phone call saying he's he's not
covered anymore so that is also
impacting billing so organizations uh
like robs like my own um there are uh
client families that are racing to try
to get
reapproved um in in the case of my
brother it was he retired in his 401k
now now makes him a wealthy
man so figuring out how he can still
receive these supports that he
desperately needs um I will try to uh
address my comments to the things that I
think will be most helpful to you I do
want to mention that uh we as an
organization are relatively fortunate
and that because we do straddle two
states and we address various different
needs we do have a halftime Finance
director a halftime billing clerk um who
has already been using uh mmis in the
state of Maine we did make the decision
uh despite attending all of the sessions
which we're very grateful for that uh
BDS uh and DHHS put on for us uh that uh
many if not most of us from PPN did
attend uh that it was best for us to go
through a third party provider uh one
sky was the one uh third party provider
who uh came and spoke to PPN and spoke
to what they would be able to do which I
greatly appreciated one sky is one of
the two area agencies that we had
experience working with so we' worked
with Mr Cordo uh in the past and felt
very comfortable making that transition
that said although it's it's been a
relatively smooth transition from that
perspective there have been some billing
delays I did try to put together just an
anecdotal piece because I know that was
a question um Madam chairwoman that you
mentioned previously uh we do have uh
our first payments related to the
beginning of July we received
approximately mid August um we have
approximately 3 weeks worth of
receivables that are over 3 weeks past
due and about one week uh worth of
receivables uh that are greater than 60
days P du um I do want to say that I'm
I'm grateful that we don't provide any
case management or Service Coordination
out of great Bas Services because it's
my impression that a great deal of of
this work has fallen to them uh that
does generally speaking uh speak to the
what the area agencies are going through
uh because the vast majority of uh case
managers and service coordinators are
employed by the area agencies um we are
thrilled to be this involved in the
conversation about rate setting
uh we all did kind of feel a bit falling
off the edge of a cliff uh as of July
1st I know that's not what anyone wanted
I had a bit of a feeling like all of us
were with our eyes closed trying to
describe an elephant by feel uh and all
of us were paying attention to our own
little piece and not necessarily getting
a full picture through I I feel no fault
of of anyone's we we tried our best to
be prepared and I'm grateful that we
decided to go through a third party uh
to to do our Medicaid billing despite
our experience billing with Medicaid uh
in the state of Maine um so we did have
that experience of falling off the cliff
and there is some anxiety about the
other shoe to fall hoping there's not
another Cliff approaching but with that
said this open conversation and and our
involvement in it does give give me and
I know my peers on PPN a great deal of
of comfort and I I again appreciate the
opportunity thank
you thank you so much for providing that
in hopefully you'll stay involved thank
you thank
you is there anyone else who would like
you thank you madam chair and members of
the committee I I realize you've been
here a long time but I will uh I'll try
to be as brief as I can Alex kbis with
Denny and ble representing the Community
Support Network the association of the
10 a agencies I I I just want to give
you and I really appreciate the the
presentation from the Department I I it
was um good to see that there wasn't a
lot of finger pointing and um blaming
you know the sides of the issue but you
know I do I do represent a lot of
different um employees and and families
who want me to have you know say certain
things on the record we haven't had an
opportunity as the area agency
collectively to to speak to you really
since the hearings on these bills uh
back in in February and March so I just
want to give you a kind of a flavor for
how things have progressed since July
1st from our perspective so there is a
little bit uh you reflecting on the past
but also I think there's a there's a
hopeful message at the end where I think
we are making some progress particularly
in the last week or so to to try and
move this forward so uh if you'll just
permit me to go through some opening
remarks here that I have
um so again you obviously you heard from
from the department for about an hour
and we do think it's important that you
hear from the the provider Community as
well because we have a different
experience and we represent uh different
constituencies and and from the air
agency's perspective one one one
moment we did hear one week ago yes from
the gentleman sitting next to you yes
you did at Great length yes you did so
let's not have quite so much no
opportunity to be heard yes uh thank you
understood representative I appreciate
that I just want to make sure you can
just go ahead I just want to make sure
that that was noted
absolutely thank you very much my name
is m I'm the CEO for one sky um I think
where this testimony differs is this is
the collective group um and not so much
just from my region thank you yes and
and certainly on behalf of the agenes we
appreciate you know this it's a Friday
afternoon and and we appreciate you all
being here we all know how much you get
paid and it's not very much so we I I I
don't mean to uh imply that you haven't
been you haven't afforded us the
opportunity uh we just haven't had as a
as a collective uh we have not been
before you I should say is the way to uh
explain that so from the air agency's
perspective uh the go live has really
there there's been a lot of chaos and
confusion frankly since July 1st and
many of the air agency staff who have
worked in the system for a long time
have told me that they felt really
stressed overwhelmed hopeless uh they've
never experienced this level of uh
dysfunction not able to do not able to
perform their job that they want to do
which is to help people and to serve the
community uh in addition as you heard
most area agencies are experiencing
Financial challenges uh and financial
shortfalls and this has required the
agencies to apply for the stabilization
funds uh from the Department or some of
them have had to rely on credit lines
from from Banks and other financial
institutions some area agencies are
freezing hiring they're freezing wages
they're delaying necessary and important
projects and you these actions are the
result of the uh the corrective action
plan and the implementation uh in in
July
um this is in spite of us adopting a new
budget that had millions of dollars in
Medicaid rate increases so it's not you
know it's it's it's with a lot of
disappointment that I'm reporting to
that some air agencies are freezing
wages I don't think any of us would have
thought that when we were all
celebrating the the state budget that we
passed but you know that's where we are
and again I don't want to reiterate too
much in the past but because I haven't
spoke for the agencies um really since
the the winter on this we obviously know
that we we had a really bad data
migration I mean that really is a huge
part of this issue and again from the a
agency perspective we were too slow to
acknowledge the cause of the issues with
the data migration and we were too slow
to begin to fix it and and as you know
the challenges that everyone's facing
here are around billing and software
glitches serice service authorizations
and a lot of growing pains because the
air agencies used to upload their client
documents into E Studio and now they
have to upload it into New Hampshire
easy and many of the air agencies feel
that they weren't given the proper
training and tools to be successful with
that transition and as you heard again I
don't want to reiterate but I just want
to get it on the record many of the
software problems are around bad data
entries missing information mismatching
names and these issues require a great
deal of time to fix and there's not a
lot of people in this world who can fix
these issues uh the state HHS and their
other Consultants who run these systems
they're the ones that really have the
control we can't go in and necessarily
fix a lot of these issues as the area
agency
So In fairness there are issues on the
air agency side as well um as you heard
there's problems with the uh area
agency's internal Billing System and we
are working to address that and we have
to own those those challenges as well um
so I guess the bottom line here is from
our point of view the train is is off
the track and we've got to get the train
back on the track and we can argue
should we have piloted a section of the
track and tested it out and you know
that's in the past it's off the track
we've got to work to get the train back
on the track the train can't go back to
June 30 it can only move forward so we
all have to move forward together we
want to work together we don't want to
be finger pointing we don't want to be
arguing with each other uh we have to
work as partners providers and and the
department to try and and bring come
together to resolve this issue because
there's a lot of people who depend on
that train being on the track and those
are the people that get the services uh
so to that end now I'm going to sort of
transition to the positivity uh we did
have a a really productive meeting with
the uh the the air agency leadership and
the department leadership had a meeting
on Monday of this past week and we
discussed the system transformation uh
pretty in depth and the are agencies
left that meeting cautiously optimistic
that our concerns were heard and they
the concerns have been I think elevated
to a new level of uh not that they
weren't heard before but I think there's
a a increased Consciousness with the
decision makers at the department to um
really get get behind some of the things
that we're saying and and to try to
resolve some of these challenges so
we're cautiously optimistic that uh
there's an elevated awareness and that
we have a path forward so I think those
are two really important positive uh
developments that have happened this
week we went into the meeting as the
area agencies with with really a simple
ask that we we need to clean up the New
Hampshire easy implementation and that
is that is the system that has all this
bad data from mmis as you heard from the
gentleman from from madok uh we need to
stabilize cash flow and we can't be
interrupted by any new initiatives we
have to be focused like a laser on the
corrective action plan and imple
implementing that and getting it right
and getting these providers on on a firm
footing so the good news is that as you
heard from the Department today they uh
they seem to be understanding the fact
that the system is very fragile right
now and it cannot take on uh new
initiatives we need to get what's what
we're working on now right before we
move forward so specifically electronic
visit verification yes it's been around
since 2016 but I mean how how much have
we really been focused on it since 2016
I would argue you know not very much
there's there's a vendor that's behind
right now we're hearing that it may go
live in March uh we we don't think that
that's going to be enough time to to
resolve these issues so we would we
would Advocate that evv be put off even
if it does cost a little bit in fines we
feel that that cost is is probably
modest when you compare trying to layer
on another major systems change
particularly a software systems change
which is a lot of what evv is going to
end up being onto the system right now
uh the folks who are in the trenches at
the a agencies can't be going to more
meetings about some new system
transformation it just it it will break
the system in my opinion uh changes to
the financial management services so
this is what we're looking for and the
department has agreed to this they
testified to it today we need to delay
the implementation of rate and
wraparound broker Services uh this has a
significant impact as you heard on the
participant managed Services which is
basically the the services that are
managed by a family
member uh we need to reconfigure the
paybacks to match any improvements in
the system so as we start to clean up
New Hampshire easy and we start to get
more comfortable and and agencies start
to get paid more
regularly then we can start looking more
aggressively at the payback but until
that happens we think it's premature to
to have that date in there now the
department has said that they're not
willing to globally uh be flexible on
that it's they want to look at it more
from an individual agency perspective uh
I think we would probably prefer some
some more Global flexibility around the
p paybacks and then uh it's not really
directly related to the cap but again
I've been asked by by by the area
agencies and and the people that they
support and represent to talk a little
bit about the the Medicaid rate
increases uh we we need those
implemented as soon as possible I don't
think it's going to happen before
January 1st technically the department
is in compliance if they uh execute
those rate increases by January 1st uh I
think a lot of folks were hoping that
they would recognize the workforce
crisis and and get those out a little
bit sooner they they technically have
until January 1st to do it they could do
it earlier if they want to uh it doesn't
seem like that's going to
happen uh that's their right I I just I
I wanted to just express our
disappointment that they weren't able to
get the money on the street a little bit
sooner
um but again we've been assured that
they will they will provide those rate
increases by January 1st and that will
obviously help
uh with cash flow and and with uh
Recruitment and Retention of
staff so in closing uh as I said we had
a good meeting on Monday we recommitted
I think both sides to try and start a
new and look
forward we're going to have bi-weekly
meetings with with the area
agencies and the department staff the
decision makers at the department to try
and get this back on track and uh
I think we left the meeting with a
commitment on both sides that yes things
have been rough since July 1 but that we
together we can work on a smoother path
forward to try and um to try and get the
system where everyone wants it to be
because I agree with um with Pam who
spoke before no no nobody wanted this to
happen obviously um but it has happened
we have to deal with it as I said we
can't we can't bring the train back to
June 30th we just have to work together
to try to bring the train back and you
know I do think there's a role for the
legislature to um as as we've talked
about holding these types of meetings
you know I don't know that legislation
is going to really fix the problem I
think really what's going to fix the
problem is time it's going to take time
to work these Kinks out with the
software uh there's there's not really a
Magic Bullet but I think if we if we can
signal to the area agencies and the
provider community that we're not going
to layer on new requirements at the
moment until we we get our house in
order and then we can be a little more
flexible with the paybacks so the people
can uh pay their staff and deliver the
services I think that's going to go a
long way towards um giving us some
comfort and a little bit of breathing
room to try to clean up this this know
somewhat of a mess that we're
in thank you representative
nichel thank you that answered a lot of
my questions and thoughts and comments
and I would also add that community
indication as part of the process too
which you've already alluded to um what
do you think about the concept of
interim study for this
bill uh I think interim study makes
sense if it as a if it's a true interim
study I mean I think if you're asking me
what is the role what can you do as the
legislature to help solve this problem
it's it's a great question um I think
having meetings like this staying
involved um frankly putting pressure on
the department when you think that we're
um we have points that are that are not
getting through as as representative
marchan said I mean they they do Drive
the Bus obviously I mean uh a lot of
these
decisions they are very collaborative we
we talk to them all the time but
sometimes um you need a little bit of a
legislative push as you know I mean
that's often times why a lot of bills
are introduced as as most of you know um
so if you can be an advocate for your
constituents hold meetings like this try
to bring both sides together together
and and and help us um Elevate the
issues um as I said the meeting that you
had the representative Weber um
reference I think the meeting we had on
Monday was a result of the subcommittee
the previous subcommittee that you had
all of that concern that was raised by
this committee by you hosting that
meeting that I think created a positive
action and and then that's going to
continue to move forward so if if the
department knows that the legislature
will stay engaged I think it's just a
little extra check that um you know that
you're watching not not that they need
to be watched don't don't misunderstand
me but um it it it does help us it it
does help us to have you as advocates
and someone that we can um that we can
go to with concerns and that you can try
to Advocate on our behalf when you think
that it's
appropriate thank you there other
representative
Merchant this is actually a question
thank you madam chair um question for my
steam colleague to my right ter
we and looking at the Department of
Health Human Services and the oversight
committee is it possible to create
a subcommittee of that committee without
going through the legislative process
what I'm trying to get to is I think the
communication between the all the
parties has been shown to be beneficial
to all um instead of going through a
legislative process to create something
that could doal with the Alzheimer's
subcommittee of that oversight committee
is it possible for the committee itself
or the chair of that committee to
convene a subcommittee of different
parties so we don't lose momentum that
we created um as we go through the inim
study so at that point in time I guess
my colleague to my right give her a
chance here to speak is can we do that
as a oversight
committee Madam chair if I may reply um
yes we can but my what I'm hearing here
first of all what you do is you submit
and it's all in statute you submit a
written request to the oversight
committee to establish a subcommittee
and you give an outline of what the
subcommittee is supposed to be doing and
it can be voted on by the oversight
committee and that's one thing that
absolutely can be done it seems to me
that it might be more
effective uh to Simply make sure that as
a
part of the interim study
process that either we or an ad
hoc um subcommittee of the health and
human conservices committee which is the
other way you can do it meets and I
think we've got
enough uh motivation between all of the
people sitting here to keep the process
going
forward um that um you know I would do
it under the intern study committee and
keep things going that way but if there
was any push back with that either an ad
hoc committee which can simply be named
by our chair or a subcommittee official
subcommittee of Health and Human
Services can be implemented if if people
feel
like what we hope keeps happening going
forward isn't happening so we've got a
lot of a lot of options
there thank you I think we've actually
built a of knowledge here amongst the
people here um and I think that doing it
within the Health and Human Services
committee would mean that we don't need
to go back to Prior ground this is such
a dynamic situation than moving forward
as a subcommittee of Health and Human
Services um and then moving towards
interim study would probably be most
helpful so I I saw another hand that
there may be somebody else who wants to
speak with us um I I don't see any other
qu questions for these gentlemen thank
you so much for everything that you
brought forward this is one of those
that brings us the do the information
and and I do know that we have people
that do have some other appointments but
we want to
also we want to also U make sure that
we're going to hear I think one last
hands good afternoon thank you so much I
don't want to take up too much time for
the record my name is Lisa Bodwin I'm a
disability and Health Care policy
consultant and a former executive
director of a nonprofit here in New
Hampshire that advocates for people with
disabilities so I have a a a long
history of being on the team um and I'm
here today wearing my hat as a family
member and that voice you haven't heard
from today and I don't think you heard
from that Voice last week
so I would like to say that the
department has worked really hard at all
stages of this the staff and the
department are really dedicated to
trying to make the DD system a more
robust system so that people with
disabilities can have incredibly
inclusive lives there is no doubt that
everyone in the department is working
really incredibly hard um and that a lot
of collaboration has happened so that
has to be said
um anecdotally I am hearing from
families that service coordinators are
so overwhelmed by the new responsibility
is that they're leaving their jobs and
there'll be data on that in the next six
weeks or so I also want to remind the
committee that families in New Hampshire
are in fact the backbone of the DD
system um we have a severe housing
shortage and we have a severe Workforce
shortage so much of what um happens to
support individuals who are adults with
developmental disabilities happens on on
the backs of families and family members
um give U thousands tens of thousands of
dollars of free labor to support their
adult individuals who they are not
legally responsible to house or um
become dsps for which there are many
brothers sisters Aunts Uncles and even
parents who are now having to be paid as
a DSP um because the workforce shortage
uh getting the rates up and going would
go a long way toward strengthening the
workforce to help alleviate some of the
stress on the families and we really
want to make sure that service
coordinators um are getting what they
need um because we cannot have the the
impacts to the service providers and the
way that service providers are having to
Bank in weekend hours to deal with
billing great setting prior
authorizations um we can't have those
staff leaving because then families will
start
feeling the systemic change which is
ultimately supposed to be supporting
individuals to have more robust
community-based
lives
um that's those are my notes I
appreciate your time uh today and I know
that everyone is working really hard to
collaborate on the ultimate goal which
is um a world where people with
disabilities are embraced have a feeling
of belonging have access to work have
access to Rotary clubs
voting um and the Appalachian Mountain
Club equally to their peers without
disabilities so let's keep staying
focused that this is really about the
the people thank you thank you and thank
you so much for sharing that with us we
really appreciate you being here and for
everything you do um I I think we've
seen just how important this is and how
important it is to keep moving forward
and doing this in the New Hampshire way
um with that I would be willing to
motion okay I I would move interim study
on House Bill
608 uh with a committee report that
includes Our intention to work on the
bill going forward to work on not the
bill but the global situation going
forward um so that everybody is still in
touch and so that people have this as a
forum going
forward and uh oh thank you I'll second
second by representative kofalt thank
you and with that I will call the role
representative Nagel yes representative
kofalt yes representative Weber yes yes
representative Merchant yes
representative frus yes representative
Lon is a yes so that is uh six zero so
we will recommend this to interim study
and uh we're not going to let our heels
cool off let's make sure that we show
this as an example of just how well we
can all work together and make the best
services available for everybody and
find any solutions we may need going
forward legislatively we want to make
sure that the budget next time around
also reflects everybody's needs so thank
you
adjourned